Stall point. The stall point is a tricky topic — it's the second-most-common cause of accidents in
paragliding: stopping the wing from flying forward — entering a thermal,
or while thermalling, simply applying too much brake and getting too close to that
stall speed without noticing, and unintentionally stalling
the wing. At low altitude that's of course fatal, and at higher altitude you simply
need to have run through this whole thing once and to know it. We've also talked about this
many times in the exam material. The stall point is the point where — you all know this —
you pull on the brakes, pull very deep, until the wing no longer flies forward,
but first goes into deep stall, and afterwards could end up
going into backward flight. Deep stall is this transition, and now the wing needs,
once it's reached deep stall, a very clear signal — should it go forward again, or
should it go backwards. The stall point of course announces itself in
various ways. We can feel it through the brake — through the
pressure. The deeper you pull the brake, the stronger the pressure gets. Once we've
reached the stall point, that strong pressure we had down there suddenly
releases. Like a shot from a pistol — suddenly there's no pressure at all, bang,
hands immediately have to go up. Or you can also observe it visually,
meaning if you look at the wing, at first it's still nicely filled out wide,
the harder you pull on the brake, the closer we get to the stall point. Once we've
reached it, the wing no longer flies forward but is in deep stall. However, the
span of the wing — from wingtip to wingtip — is still there. That means the
extension is still there, but now the air mass pushes from below up onto the wing — meaning
you can see how the bottom surface bulges upward, making real belly shapes,
and that's a sign that you've reached the stall point. And those two factors —
you have to take them a bit independently from each other. It can be that you first see it visually
on the wing and only feel it a second later on the brake, which for example could already be a big
problem, or the other way around — you feel it first on the brake before you perceive it on the wing.
If so, hands simply up — when you think, where am I now, but already pretty
close, or for me already too close, hands up, we'll define that further.
I'll tell you afterwards, yes, that was missing a little bit, then you can
store that away — yes, a little bit was missing too. So to search for the stall point we have to
pull both brakes relatively far down, and so that we have a good feel there,
I'd also recommend wrapping the brakes once around. Maybe the brake lines are
so long — especially over the lake, usually in such calm air — that it can even be
that you maybe even have to wrap a second time. But let's just take
this one half-wrap and go in. You look at the wing carefully and pull the brakes very slowly,
look at the wing above you, also be aware how this brake pressure increases. So already
pull the first 20, 30 centimetres slowly, keep pulling, but slowly, watching the wing,
then you'll notice — the brake pressure becomes clearer now, gets quite hard and goes
soft — the brake pressure — you've reached the stall point. If you stay there at the stall point
and remain in that position, it transitions into stall, into flyback, and that
is what we want to avoid — we don't want that. We just want to feel this stall point,
where it is — is it here, is it here — it can be in different positions, especially when
thermalling. Then it can also be up there. Important is always one hand-up,
when you have the feeling, I'm on it — one hand-up, like I said, around two to two hands up. And
look at the wing while doing this — that means maybe you've already been able to spot it visually, okay,
I wouldn't release anything on the brake yet, but I see it visually on the wing —
then it needs both hands up briskly. What can we do if we
end up in deep stall? For example, exit the accelerator slowly — I had this once with a
very, very light girl, where we exited the accelerator slowly and she got hung up
in deep stall. That means hands are already up, we can go forward to the A-risers,
with — pull the A-risers, let go again, that would be the exit for deep stall. So
say to ten, to come back. And then the wing should start flying again afterwards.